grande do people do impressions of
people assume impressions of you don't
know very rarely yeah very rare yeah
what am I in your camera it's like I
always I feel like and I wouldn't be
able to do it until I met you but I have
do you want me don't know so I can I
have the cards I need the car okay
you're gonna but don't worry never know
over the car there's no card so welcome
so you
okay today I feel your pain ball
first time there's only the first time
for everything
but impressions everything that actors
kind of Bradley you do an impression I
do bad impersonation of Sir Ian McKellen
ask and Ralph you shall not pass wait
long trim non flem Nam and ding dong
ding dong bang dong column and Gollum
definitely not posh that's quite a good
service I don't get aggression ian
mckellen but I was in Waitrose the
supermarket here and they have those
self-service checkouts so I was at the
other checkout and Ian McKellan I said
hello to him earlier he was wandering
over the basket and I was trigger and
then just from over in the self service
area you just heard this booming voice
going it's in the bag
little so let's get little boners so
come here not me I don't know I did I'd
never that's something I'm not
what if you do got me Buxton I'm not
gonna put you down